In our last question, student OmniBeef asks,
"This might be a strange question, but I will ask it anyway.
What do you guys expect from us?
I love the idea of Udacity, and I am sure I am not the only one.
How can we help Udacity grow and be successful?"
>>Wow, that's not a strange question at all.
We love the question. We love that students are helping out, making the course grow.
The things that I have been seeing a lot of--
and I hope people will continue to do--
definitely try and encourage your friends to take a class.
We still have time to enroll more students in the class--
it's great to have as many students as possible.
There's also a lot that you are contributing by posting in the forums,
by either answering questions or asking questions.
That will enhance the quality of the class for everyone.
Also, if you can produce creative, extra materials.
We've seen some examples of that already.
That's something that will definitely enhance the class for everyone
and we'll certainly appreciate any efforts to do that.